hello guys and welcome to another
commentary video and today I have a
quick video about some stole as bad
point2 means going over some hero
ability modifies in the drool Lux
edition for a tile around I would like
to note that you can unlock all this
drew likes content by playing a game
according to a game designer Christian
advice anyway back to the hero modifiers
so its ends here that there will be two
applicability multiplies array which one
includes an me and mind control and also
the second ability modifier was revealed
when va's Star Wars Twitter the ability
reads scramble and my pals so my guess
is that when you use this ability to
might disable enemies abilities and put
them on a short cooldown do you take
this with a small grain of salt as this
is just speculation also this ability
could be a mind-control ability we read
about before but it does sound a lot
different so guess I'm they're two
different abilities anyway now to the
call of RAM abilities so it says here
that he'll also have two epic ability
multipliers except only one of them was
revealed but this one does sound pretty
cool so let's get straight into it so it
reads freeze and pool opponents with the
false so I'm guessing he will freeze the
enemy in a frozen position like it is in
the force awakens array and then I guess
we'll just pull the enemy towards him
for finishing stroke so yeah that's
about it for this video that sums
everything up so i really hope you did
enjoy this video and if you do want more
solid spied upon to news videos please
tell me horn section gallery guys please
leave me feedback in those videos anyway
made a force be with you